OWEN: Hi, and welcome
to Authors at Google.
This is my first event
that I've organized.
So I'm very proud to
have a good turn out,
and have everything
going smoothly.
Rosalind Williams has been
teaching at MIT since 1980
starting in the
writing program and now
with the program in Science,
Technology, and Society,
eventually becoming its head.
In the '90s she served
as dean of student life
in undergraduate education.
At the same time
she managed to raise
a future DBA, and an
astrophysicist, and a Swede.
Her previous book,
"Retooling," emerged
from her experience of
seeing technology launched
by an institution come
back later to change it.
And many of her other
works she uses literature
to get a phone call
during the [INAUDIBLE].
She uses literature to study
the history of technology.
And that's what she's done with
"Triumph of the Human Empire."
I'm happy to present
Rosalind Williams.
ROSALIND: Thank
you very much Owen.
This is like a classroom.
Everybody's at the back.
You can creep up if you care to.
But even though I spend
time in the classroom
I like to be a
historian who's talking
not only to other historians.
So I really appreciate
your coming,
spending the time and attention,
and I'll be very interested
in your feedback.
So the beginning is always
a good place to start.
And the beginning
here is the title
of this book, ie. what I've been
thinking about for the last 10
years.
So I want to start by explaining
the key words in that title,
especially "human
empire," but also
what do we mean
by its "triumph."
What's with the "end of the
world" and why these three
guys, Verne, Morris,
and Stevenson?
So I'm going to start with
the phrase "human empire"
because it's the
key to the rest.
And this sentence,
this one sentence,
is the key to Western
history as we know it,
to the modern world.
So I'm going to spend some
time on this sentence,
and explain first of all that
Francis Bacon, Sir Francis
Bacon, who wrote it, is a
Renaissance man in the sense
that he was a mover and shaker.
He was the equivalent of
Attorney General in Britain
in his day, and a fabulously
good writer and speaker.
But of course he's also
a real Renaissance man.
This is the Renaissance.
And so it's important
that he's writing
at this time in the
early 1600's because this
is the pivotal moment when
Westerners are beginning
to imagine history being
different from history
as the human race had
known it ever before.
This is the pivot point of
defining a new kind of history,
a history of what we
now call progress.
I mean it's a time when
Europeans have discovered what
for them is a new world.
They're busy settling it.
You notice the date.
This is when
Jamestown was settled,
Plymouth is just
getting started.
The Catholic Church has
ceased to be a monopoly.
There's now a choice of
religion after the Protestant
Reformation.
Copernicus has opened up the
idea of a whole new world
system.
Just 15 years
earlier, give or take,
Galileo has assembled
a telescope, turned it
to the heavens, has
seen the phases on Venus
and the craters on the moon.
This is a time when
the world is breaking
open from the closed
medieval world,
and everything is happening, and
all sorts of new possibilities
are out there.
And Bacon is best known for
articulating what we now
call the scientific method.
He is the guy, when you say the
Baconian method, this is Bacon,
and what you mean is a method of
experimentation of a purisicm.
And so this sentence comes
from not one of his essays.
It comes from a
fantasy novel that he
wrote called "The New Atlantis."
And in this fantasy
a group of Europeans
are shipwrecked somewhere
in the South Pacific.
They wash up on an
uncharted island
and they discover a
lost civilization.
And it's a civilization of some
lost Atlantis run by Solomon,
the ruler, who has started a
foundation, a sort of research
university on the island.
And most of the story is
telling about the research
they do on that island
in great detail.
It's quite fascinating.
This is one sentence at
the beginning of the book,
towards the beginning,
where Solomon
is telling the shipwrecked
sailors what that foundation is
all about.
And you can read it. "The
end," that is the purpose,
"of our foundation is
the knowledge of causes,
and secret motions of
things; and the enlarging
of the bounds of human
empire, to the effecting
of all things possible."
This is the agenda
for the modern world.
That's it.
That's what we're trying to do.
And it's not an empire
in a territorial sense,
like the British empire.
This is an empire in the
sense of a vast expansion
of human knowledge,
leading to more power,
leading to a better
world for humans.
It's the dream of progress.
So my question in this book
is did the dream come true?
And did this great experiment
in changing history work?
And, if so, how
would we know it?
How do you tell if
it's been successful?
It's a macro history question.
This is big history.
But I answer it
through micro history,
because while there is all
sorts of material evidence
you can point to
that humans have
come to dominate the planet
I would argue that there's
no single piece of
material evidence
that nails the case
that ultimately it's
an event of consciousness
for human beings
to conclude that we
dominate the planet,
and to conclude what the
meaning of that event is.
And I'll talk more
about this, but I really
want to focus on
people's consciousness.
When did human
beings become aware
of our domination of the planet?
And my answer is it's
the late 19th century.
And my answer is the best
way to look for this event is
through very thoughtful,
articulate, smart people,
and they happen to be writers.
Because I think if
you look at literature
you're getting consciousness.
That's where you go.
Those are the archives
of consciousness.
It's in literature.
So I'm not using these
guys as case studies.
I'm using them as
kind of allegories.
Well, maybe they're more
like-- I'm not using them
as biographies, but I'm
pulling out evidence
from their lives and
work to make my point
about the rise of and
triumph of human empire.
Now note the dates.
They're all born in the second
quarter of the 19th century
give or take.
The earliest to be born,
Verne, is the last to die,
and he lives into
the 20th century.
Morris and Stevenson
live until the 1890's.
The point though is they're
all most active as writers
in the last quarter
of the 19th century.
So they overlap.
Their lives aren't quite overlap
as much as their works do.
So they are writing
at the time when
I'm claiming that the
triumph of human empire
is becoming evident, and they
are really aware of this,
and they're really interested
in how it's happening
and what the meaning is.
So I'm just going to give
a little background sketch
of what is happening in the
greater world at that time,
later 19th century.
And I'm trying to
remind you that it's
an age of globalization
as much as ours is.
We are new but
we're not that new.
So let me give some examples.
Actually the best is
given by Verne himself.
He was interviewed in 1891,
so he was kind of 60-ish,
by an editor of a
Boston based kids
magazine, "The
Youth's Companion."
So this editor
contacted Verne and said
give me some reminiscences
of your youth,
because Verne grew up
in Nantes, in France.
So Verne wrote back.
He said, "I have seen the
birth of phosphorus matches,
stamps, the metric
system, steamboats
on the water, omni-buses,
railways, trams, gas,
electricity, the telegraph,
the telephone, the phonograph.
I am of the generation between
these two geniuses, Stevenson,
and Edison!"
Stevenson is the inventor of
the railway, effective inventor.
And Edison, we all know Edison.
So between the
railway and the dynamo
Verne says that's my
generation, and that's
a really good way
of defining it.
Another way though is just
to look at the map of world.
This is a map from 1878.
It's from a British publisher.
I don't know how
well you can see it,
but it's really-- I wish
you could because it's
a very useful map
to make my point.
In fact, when I saw this atlas
containing this map in the map
room of the Oxford library,
the Bodleian library,
I said that's it, I'm
seeing human empire.
I see it.
And one thing I saw was
the fact that up here
at the top of Greenland
it's still unfinished.
They don't quite know what
the Arctic geography is.
But most of all I
notice-- See these lines
show steamship lines and some of
them are submarine cable lines.
And they are connecting the
old world with the new world,
and where they hit the new
world you can get on a railway
and go across the United States.
This is 1878.
You can do this in
three weeks or under.
And actually Robert
Louis Stevenson
did it, because he was chasing
his American girlfriend who
lived out in Monterrey.
So three weeks from Glasgow
to the beaches of Monterrey,
which I have to say you will
hear in "Treasure Island."
"Treasure Island" is California.
It's not the Caribbean,
Johnny Depp aside.
OK?
But you can see the
wiring of the world then.
And I'll remind you
what this means.
It means, first of
all, people are moving,
and not just writers.
Between 1870 and
1925 one seventh
of the world's working age
population changed countries.
That's a huge
amount of migration.
In the same era there's much
lower cost for transport.
And it's not just
wheat opening up,
say the American West
to the European market.
It's also stuff like petroleum,
and rubber, and frozen foods
pretty soon.
And finally, there are a
lot of financial connections
that you don't see but
are implied by this.
There's the gold standard.
Investments overseas are
at a much higher rate
than they are now.
Before World War
I more than half
of the British investments
in everything were overseas.
They weren't in Britain.
So for these writers
that I'm talking about,
they love this world.
They're excited by it.
These are people who are
really interested in science
and technology as
we would now say.
And so this world of human
empire is to them thrilling.
This is Verne in his old age.
Even if you haven't
read him you know him,
because you know "20,000
Leagues Under the Sea,"
and "Around the
World in 80 Days,"
and "Journey to the Center
of the Earth," and the moon
novels.
You know him.
He was not a scientist himself.
He never claimed to be.
He never used the term science
fiction, didn't like it,
but he read everything he
could in science journalism,
as we would now say.
And so he took note cards
and many of his books
feel sort of spliced
together from these notes
that he took from this
voracious reading.
But in the moon novels
it's not only what he read,
but he also talked a
lot with his cousin who
was a physics teacher in
one of [INAUDIBLE] in Paris.
So some of the chapters
of the moon novel
were just kind of like
your physics textbook cause
he's telling you what
the trajectories are,
and how this works,
and how that works.
William Morris is not
so familiar a name
in the United States.
He's very familiar
in Britain mainly
as a writer, a poet, and a
folklorist, but he is also,
we would now say, an
entrepreneur, an innovator,
and a maker, because
his great thrill
was to manufacture household
goods for a large market.
He's a lay engineer,
running factories
to make household products
that are versatile, durable,
and beautiful.
To this day this is
my study at home.
This is a Morris chair with
a very nifty adjustable,
reclining back.
You see you just move the
pole, and you can lean back.
So Morris is, as I say, an
entrepreneur par excellence.
And finally, Robert
Louis Stevenson.
Now this is a portrait
of him in middle age.
He's living in Britain now
in the south of England.
And this is his wife, that
American wife he chased after,
finally got her to divorce
her husband, marry him.
It was quite a story.
She's on the sofa with this kind
of Indian shawl [INAUDIBLE].
He is pacing talking.
He is an intense person.
Now you know again that he
wrote "Treasure Island."
This is the map that started the
book, another uncharted island.
You also know that he wrote
"Doctor Jekyll and Mr. Hyde."
I love this cover,
the transformation,
great god, can it be.
But in the background
is this lighthouse.
And that's a reminder
Robert Louis Stevenson
is of the family of the
lighthouse Stevensons,
as they've been called.
This is a family
of Civil Engineers
who've built most if not
all of the lighthouses
that to this day stand around
the northern tier of Great
Britain.
His great grandfather, no
his grandfather, sorry, also
Robert, designed and built
the Bell Rock Lighthouse,
which is off to the east
of Edinburgh to this day.
Stevenson got a degree from
Edinburgh in engineering.
He wrote a thesis with honors.
The family expected
to be an engineer.
He wanted to be a
writer, but he always
kept his respect for engineers,
and to be very interestingly,
talks about writing
as design problems,
as engineering design problems.
Anyway, so he is a
professional engineer.
The other two are just lovers
of science and technology.
I want to just stress, these
guys love this new world,
but they are also deeply
disturbed by it, troubled
by it.
And this is a paradox
that I'm going
to be talking a little about.
They are uncompromising
in saying
it may be an interesting
world but it's not for me.
Verne's mouth piece
is Captain Nemo.
We know this from letters that
Verne was writing to his editor
when he was writing that book.
"I am not what you
call a civilized man."
This is Nemo, who was
a terrorist by the way,
seeking ships
without provocation.
He wasn't civilized.
Verne is saying
this about himself.
Morris is so disaffected that
he is a revolutionary socialist
who spent a lot of time
advocating for revolution
in Britain at a time
when Marx had died
but Engels is still there.
And this is an astounding
statement of disaffection.
"Apart from the desire to
produce beautiful things,
the leading passion
in my life has been
and is hatred of
modern civilization."
And he means it.
He really means it.
And Stevenson is
a little gentler,
but still he goes into
exile essentially.
He takes a trip
to the south seas
that ends up that
he settles there.
First he's going to
spend his winters there,
and then he decides to
move there permanently,
and essentially
throws in his lot
with the native Polynesians,
especially the Samoans.
And here he is writing
to his best friend back
home, Henry James,
trying to explain
why he's decided to
spend his life in Samoa.
"I was never fond of
towns, houses, society,
or -it seems- civilization."
They're all using this word.
What is the problem
with these guys?
They are well-to-do, bourgeois,
white, male Westerners.
The world is organized
around their benefit.
And yet that is the
feeling that they have.
What is their problem?
One way to answer it is
to go back to the maps.
This is the same atlas
that I showed you before.
OK, same atlas that
had 50 maps in all.
This is Africa in 1878.
So for Verne one way to
answer the question what
is his problem is that he
sees that he's running out
of room in the world
to write about.
You notice he wants to
map the globe in words,
but just as he and others map
the globe you lose the unknown.
It becomes all known.
There's no more mystery.
I love this map
because, look, you
can see places that have
been mapped and claimed.
Different colors are
different countries.
This is the scramble for
Africa that's going on.
But then there are these empty
areas that haven't been mapped.
Verne's first novel is
"Five Weeks in a Balloon,"
and it's the story of a journey
across this part of Africa,
trying to put together
some of the earlier maps
to make a coherent picture.
The balloon is exciting, but
once you keep mapping Africa
you're sort of
losing the adventure
of having the unknown.
Verne's second
novel is the story
of Captain Hatteras who
was an Arctic explorer.
And this captain
is going up here
trying to understand the
geography of the Arctic.
And again from the map and
the atlas, you can see,
it almost got it.
There are the names of
the expeditions here
that are listed, that
Verne listed in his novel.
So it's exciting
to think that we're
going to have the answers soon.
But once you have
the answer-- Verne
has a sense of running
out of free space.
And he's an anarchist.
He doesn't want to have to
live under somebody's command.
And there's not a lot
of that space left.
This map, same atlas,
of outer London,
OK, this is outer London.
This is inner London that
you're familiar with,
the houses of parliament
and so forth, Big Ben.
But this is what's growing
in Morris' lifetime,
and this is what bothers
him most about this world,
the expansion of urban
settlements, which he considers
crowded, ugly, constraining.
He was born and raised
near Epping Forest
just outside this area.
Actually he was raised in
the area where the London
Olympics took place a
couple years ago, which
was sort of a wasteland even
then that Morris felt still
had the beauty of the
marshland, and the rivers,
and the streams, and the
little baby Thames there,
forests, the old medieval
fortress in Epping.
He loved this.
He saw this disappearing
as the city just overflew,
like overflowed its banks.
Maybe another analogy would
be like a volcano, just kind
of throwing lava
all in this area.
So that's what bothered Morris.
And as for Stevenson, his
move to the south seas
was intended to be helping him
find better physical health,
to get some interesting
writing out of it.
It turned out to be a
lesson, he very quickly
learned, in extinction.
He saw the Polynesians literally
being extinguished as a race
by an enormously
high death rate,
especially on some islands.
It varied a lot, and
he was interested why.
But within a few days of his
landing in the Marquesas,
that was his first stop,
this island world he saw
was a dying world because
of the Western invasion.
And he felt that, he said they
are being destroyed inevitably
by our shabby civilization.
Shabby.
And this is one of his
early journal entries
about his landing.
This is like two days after
he landed in the Marquesas,
and he's realizing
these are dying people.
And what's so interesting
is he says it's not just
they're dying, we're
going to die too.
We're in this together.
Their case will be as ours,
"death coming in like a tide."
So all three of these writers
have real fundamental, not just
quarrels, but arguments
with civilization
as it's being defined
by the expansion
of human empire in their time.
So what I'd like to do
now is describe, briefly,
how they dealt
with this, and how
they came to terms living
in this kind of a world.
And the answer is romance.
And by that I don't mean
"Fifty Shades of Grey."
I don't mean erotic romance,
though there's an element.
Or I don't even mean
chick lit kind of you
know adult romance,
softer stuff.
What I mean is a much
broader, deeper understanding
of what romance has been
in world literature.
It's basically the oldest kind
of literature that humans have,
telling stories about heroes
that aren't quite superhuman
but are more than
normally human.
Stories that are not
entirely fantastic,
but are not constrained
by every day reality.
In the words of Henry
James, Stevenson's friend,
romance is
experienced liberally,
experienced liberally.
So not unreal but free.
So the Ur example are the
legends of King Arthur.
King Arthur was nice.
Those are romance stories.
There are Norse sagas that
so entranced Morris and that
make the basis of
Wagnerian opera.
Those are other examples.
They consider Atlantis
as a romance, shipwreck,
undiscovered island.
Now romance lost some
prestige with the rise
of the novel, which is much more
focused on every day realism,
both social and
material, but romance
endures even if it
doesn't have the respect
that the novel typically has.
There are graphic novels
that lead to Stephen King.
There is historical novels
that start with Sir Walter
Scott, lead to
Hillary [INAUDIBLE].
There's just creepy stories
like Edgar Allan Poe wrote.
These are all
examples of romance,
and that's what I'm
talking about when
I talk about these three writers
all wrote romance, and not
only wrote it, they
found their salvation
in reading and writing romance.
They all set out to
do this, but they all
changed the kind of
romance that they
wrote to fit their interests
in what we would now
call science and technology.
So Verne, here he is.
I showed you the old Verne.
I want to show you the young
Verne, just to remind you.
Yes, he was young once.
This is when he first
arrives in Paris.
He's in his early 20's.
He's going to conquer the world.
He's going to be a
great playwright.
Well, that didn't work
out, but 20 years later
what he did do was invent
the geographical romance.
That's what he
called his stories.
He said collectively they
are extraordinary voyages,
extraordinary journeys.
That's what intrigued him.
And that formula was
enormously successful.
He wrote 80 odd of these novels.
Many of them were staged.
Made a lot of money for him.
But he has this
attitude of defiance
that he's going to go where
he wants to go and not
be constrained by
Western Europe.
He doesn't write
about Western Europe.
That's home.
That's boring.
He writes about other
people and other events.
This is an illustration from
"20,000 Leagues Under the Sea,"
the original edition, and if
you just read the words of Verne
you're missing the
illustrations that
go in these early editions
here are fabulous.
This is Nemo on the deck of
the Nautilus, arms crossed.
He's also defiant, looking
at that British frigate
that he's going
to sink very soon.
And this is terrorism
but it's thrilling.
And Nemo, of course, has just
become an icon of modern world,
I suggest because that world
feels pretty constraining,
and romance gives us
a hero who defies it.
James Mason who was the
Disney version, or just
these endless mash-ups
of Captain Nemo
doing whatever that defies
the rest of civilization.
So Morris also,
I'm going back to
the young, vulnerable Morris.
This is a self portrait
just to remind you.
He was not always an old man.
This is when he married a
gorgeous but difficult woman.
But all these guys have marriage
stories worth going into,
but we'll skip that for now.
I remind you that Morris
started as a medievalist.
He was starting with
the King Arthur stories.
But when he discovered the
Norse language and Norse sagas
the land of Iceland
became for him
another land where
real stories could
be told that could
no longer be told
in London, in outer London.
So he went to Iceland on a
couple of trips in the early
1870's.
These are pony
trek trips that he
took as a sort of
Bourgeois adventure,
and he began to
think about stories
that were set in
places like Iceland
but aren't in any real place.
It was a place that offered
him an imaginative alternative.
And so out of this
Morris invented
a new kind of romance,
which we now call fantasy.
He invented secondary worlds.
That's Tolkein's phrase.
Tolkien, like Morris,
studied Icelandic, taught it.
The two of them
are very similar,
and Tolkien is really
a disciple of Morris'.
So if you haven't heard
of Morris you should.
This is his first fantasy novel,
"The Story the Glittering Plain
or the Land of the Living Men."
The one that's best
known and longest,
"The Well at the World's End."
This chapter reminds us there
is always eroticism there.
"The Chamber of Love
in the Wilderness."
That's the story of that.
That's the title of
that illustration there.
These books he produced
with a press that he started
called Kelmscott
Press, because he
felt that ordinary printing
was unworthy of these stories.
He wanted a sort of
magical feel to them.
So Morris is just
extraordinary for just
leaving the world
behind and inventing
a whole new kind of
romance famously.
Robert Louis Stevenson-- This
is the defiant Stevenson.
When he was entering
university to study engineering
he has a velvet jacket
on and long hair,
and he's no engineer.
Or he's going to at least
show that to others.
But Stevenson really
expanded and reconfigured
his own understanding of
romance through 20 years
of difficulties, some of them
health, some of them related
to his exile.
As I say you know him
from "Treasure Island,"
and from stories like "Jeckel
and Hyde," or "Kidnapped."
But when he got
to the south seas
he started writing
much grittier romances.
I mean maybe this
is an image of what
you would think
the south seas is.
This is Stevenson on the right
fanning his wife who is just
below the palm tree,
two Polynesians.
They look like hippies
on the lawn here,
but this is an interlude
in a much tougher world,
particularly when
Stevenson got to Samoa.
It was in the midst
of colonial wars
involving Germany,
Britain, and America.
So one of the first
things he wrote in Samoa
is what we would now
call new journalism.
And he wrote about these
words in a little pamphlet
titled "A Footnote to History."
And he meant that ironically.
In other words it now looks
like a footnote to history,
but these dirty little wars
are going to be history.
That's the message.
And that's why this book
is well worth reading.
But he also, in lots of
conversations with Polynesians,
picked up some of their tails
and retold them in English
for both the Polynesian
and a Western audience.
This is Stevenson
on the front deck
of the house he lived in
in Samoa, his wife Fanny.
Her daughter is down here.
Son here, son in-law.
And Stevenson's mother,
who is there from Scotland.
She came all the way from
Edinburgh to live with her son
after her husband's death.
So there she is in
her widow's cap.
I mean I just think this image
is just really something,
but as a writer Stevenson
found all sorts of new material
and ways of looking
at the world in Samoa.
And he wrote, as I
say, some from legends,
but he also wrote some
very tough, gritty stories
of criminality, greed,
and sexual exploitation
in the south seas.
The best of them
is "The Ebb-Tide."
It's a book about the length
of "Heart of Darkness."
It's better.
You should read it, and
this is the first sentence.
"Throughout the island
world of the Pacific,
scattered men of
many European races
and from almost every
grade of society
carry activity and
disseminate disease."
Now if I were in a
lit class I would
go over every word, every
word, because it's meaningful.
Here's another sentence like
Bacon's that just says so much,
and that's just
the first sentence.
Read that story.
Those writings of
Stevenson in his day
were either ignored
or ridiculed.
Nobody took them seriously.
People wanted more
"Treasure Island" kind of.
And Stevenson, no, that's not
what he was interested in.
He said, I have a romance of
destiny, romance of destiny,
it has led me here, and
this is what I'm writing.
So I just want to
wrap up by kind
of following up on that
statement of Stevenson's,
and talking about the way
these three writers help
us think about human
empire both as progress
and the end of the world.
It's both, at least
that's their conclusion.
For one thing they all
remind us that what
we're going through today
in the sense of a highly
constrained and human
dominated world, it's new
but it's not completely new.
They felt they were
living in such a world,
and they were trying to figure
out how to live best in it.
And I don't want to turn
them into self help writers.
They are not.
But there are some
examples that they
set that I think are
worth pointing out.
The first one is that
they are realistic.
They understand,
want to understand
how the world is and not
invade the facts of life.
In fact, CS Lewis, another
famous writer, very fond
of Morris, wrote about Morris.
He said Morris has
faced the facts.
So facing the facts
is-- These are realists.
They also love romance.
And the argument
I'm trying to make
is in some ways romance helps us
face facts more than just kind
of brutal enumeration
of material conditions,
because it takes into account
humans needing stories
and symbols to
understand the world.
Second thing is they all
have a lot of courage.
This is the defiance.
They're going to do
what they want to do,
and it doesn't
matter if they lose.
It doesn't matter if their
book sales don't go up.
It doesn't matter if people
don't appreciate them.
If there's something
they want to do,
and they just say this is my
adventure, I'm going to do it,
and I don't have to
win to be successful.
And third, and this is
very interesting in a world
where so many people want
to save the world, right?
Yeah, they want
to save the world,
they want the revolution, they
are out there actively trying
to make it a better
place, but they also
believe they have a duty
and a right to happiness,
and that it's a beautiful world,
and part of the human duty
is to enjoy it, and
to think about this
and actively seek ways
of enjoying the world.
So they realize the
live in human empire,
but they are trying to
liberate their experience,
and to create a
human world that's
livable and beautiful
within human empire.
Thank you.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: What I think
empire in the usual sense of
say a society within
humanity having
territory and power there
are two aspects, one of them
is spread, scope, and
the other one is control.
When we think of
human empire I see
that as how much of the
population of creatures,
whether it be humans or
whatever, spreads and takes
over the food supply,
takes over the water
supply, and so on,
possibly slamming
into the wall with
population growth,
versus understanding and
ability to make the setting
work for it?
So we have both of
those with humanity.
We're clearly in disagreement
with some people about
whether we're crashing head
long into a wall or not,
but I see these as
both important factors
but very different factors in
the growth of human empire.
And those who believe we've
only extend the empire to space
soon enough to avoid greater
overcrowding problems,
[INAUDIBLE] much greater
problems on Earth,
have fantasies or romances
in that direction.
It seems to me there's
still a large space
that you didn't cover in this
talk, I guess the initial talk.
Do your writings cover
those dimensions as well?
ROSALIND: So tell--
There's a lot
to respond-- No this
is a great comment.
But tell me what space
you're asking about.
AUDIENCE: Oh, at
least once when I
used the word space
I meant expanding
to space stations, or
the moon, or some such,
but also the topic
area of human empire.
It seems to me there are those
two very different dimensions
of it.
ROSALIND: Yeah, at least two
and maybe more, but certainly
in human empire and also
just in more normal empires,
the sense of the British
empire, whatever, there's
control of territory,
but then there's
control of what goes on
within the territory.
That's very different.
And some empires
are famously loose.
It's like whatever
can go on, and there's
a lot of local autonomy,
and others are much more
controlling.
So there's that distinction,
and it's not clear.
I don't think it's clear yet
sort of how human empire fits
into that spectrum.
I think what is obvious is
that domination is not control.
I would say that humans dominate
what happens on the planet.
You name a topic, the human
influence is paramount.
It doesn't mean we
control what goes on.
So that's the problem in
fact, or one of the problems
is the domination
without the control.
In terms of going
to outer space,
and that is just I
think a way of saying,
yeah there's a lot more to
the cosmos than the Earth,
but realistically speaking the
numbers of people on the Earth,
the expense of-- I
mean imaginatively it's
very important.
Realistically, pragmatically I
have not booked my ticket yet.
AUDIENCE: So I was just
interested actually
in your choice to focus
on British writers.
I think the time period they're
kind of writing in, living in,
I see a lot of the
same things happening
in like the expansion of
the West, transcontinental
railroad, obviously
Africa kind of came up,
and their view I
think could probably
be expanded to look at
a few other regions that
were going through very
similar transformations
if not more dramatic
at that time period.
I wasn't sure if it was just for
the sake of [INAUDIBLE] if you
started to see this happening
in writers that were writing out
the West or explorers that
were in Africa at some
of the same time?
ROSALIND: Well,
I work with a lot
of people who only
write about the United
States or the Americans.
So part of it was a little
rebelliousness on my part.
It's like you know,
there are other people
who are-- You could write
an American version of this,
but to some extent
Leo Marx already
has in "The Machine
in the Garden."
So I would point
you there to look
at this theme with
American writers.
I think you could take any
part of the world in this time
period, any literary tradition.
Gabriel Garcia Marquez
has written about it
in the "Hundred
Years of Solitude."
This is his theme.
I could go through sort of--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
guess I was just
wondering if you see it as a
war of like the consciousness
of the time or [INAUDIBLE]
a product of there.
Because it is such a global
phenomenon during this time
period, which is sometimes
uncanny in literature,
where you have so many different
writers who never have met
or read each others' works
writing in such similar themes.
ROSALIND: Exactly.
Yes, I would say that.
And taking these
three guys is in part
because I wanted to
focus on this paradox
that they are the winners, or
that they are the people you
would expect to
be most satisfied.
I mean you can see why
somebody writing from Polynesia
is not going to be real
happy about what's going on,
but you would think--
So it's the kind
of counter intuitive nature
of their dissatisfaction
that interested me, and just
the fact it's a big world,
many too many people
to write about.
But I really regard the
book as opening a door,
and I would love other people
to start thinking about this
and thinking of other ways of
thinking about human empire,
thinking about writing.
There's a whole age of the
anthropocene discussion going
on that I think this
really relates to.
I think that's just
another terminology
for similar analysis.
So I don't at all mean for
this to be, OK, read the book
and that's the end of it.
It's door opening
books that I like,
and I would like this
to be one of them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Is there some general things
you could say about the way
that the three of
them articulated
what was being lost?
Was there any kind
of generality?
I mean, you talked about
their dissatisfaction.
Was there some other
themes that they
shared about what
was actually being
lost in that transformation?
ROSALIND: Most
generally that when
you live in a human
condition of human domination
you lose so much.
It's the sense of loss of ways
of life, ways of thinking,
experiences that humans
need to make us human.
And once you displace
the non-human
you become less human.
And each of them could
name somewhat different
what those experiences are.
It's like humanity
works fine if you
have other things in the
world, but the moment
that you essentially have
a monoculture then it's
harder to be human
because there's
nothing else, no other scale of
reference or mode of reference.
All right.
That's a really great question.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
about the use of the word
civilization.
It seems to me that would have
meant something substantially
different than now.
When What trying
to think of what
they might have meant by
it, civilizing influence
is basically the
collective pressure
on people to behave
less like their nature
in order to get along.
And it seems to me,
the more crowded
we get the more
organizations dominate rather
than individuals or
families dominate
behavior in a town square.
If it's a village it's a
few families getting along.
If it's a big city there are
enormous city rule impositions
controlling how things
go in that little place
where a few people live around
because of all the other people
who live within a mile or two.
Do you see it as that
kind of, you could call it
governmental pressure on
people's behavior, that's
part of the problem?
ROSALIND: I would
just say organized,
because the organizations
can be non-governmental.
They can be commercial
or whatever.
Again, I think you really put
your finger on a major theme
here.
The word civilization,
thanks to Google,
now we can go back and find
it everywhere in the past,
and scholars are greatly aided
by having search engines that
allow us to pull out that
word, and see where it is,
and see patterns, and so forth.
There's also, I will say, the
Oxford English Dictionary,
which gives contextual usages.
So we can study that word.
But you're right
that it, for them,
is pointing to what is generally
a plus thing, because there's
non-civilized or uncivilized.
That's bad.
I mean that's a word that's used
a lot in this era and even now,
I mean uncivilized.
So civilization is good.
So for them to be saying
I am having trouble
with it is somewhat rebellious.
I would say that beginning in
the early 1900's there is just
a fundamental disconnect
in Western civilization
between a real emphasis on the
individual as having rights,
and liberties, and a future, and
a story that's worth telling.
This you find in romanticism,
you find in democracy,
you find in the invention of
the word individualism by de
Tocqueville in the 1830's.
The whole romantic movement
in that large sense
says you matter,
you matter a lot,
and you should follow your
bliss, and write your poetry.
And these romance writers
believed that and follow it.
But it's the same era when the
increasing powers of humanity
are creating more and
more systems, right,
that constrain
individuals, and that,
yes, bring progress of certain
types that are undeniable.
But these two things
are happening together.
And I think we still
live in a world
where that tension is
very real, and each of us
struggles with it.
The sociologist Manuel Castells
has brought this idea up
to date by saying there are two
things going on in the world.
This is in his trilogy
on the information age.
One thing is the development of
networks which are, especially
financial, but
also technological
of all sorts, networks
that connect us.
And there's also a quest for
identity, for self, who am I,
and where do I fit, who do I
belong to, what matters to me.
So Castells says
network and self.
I would say romanticism, or
romance, and civilization.
These are two variations on the
theme of a fundamental tension,
and tensions make the world
interesting but not easy.
AUDIENCE: I think there
may be another aspect
to the reaction, their
reaction, to civilization.
I'm thinking particularly
[INAUDIBLE] but may well
[INAUDIBLE], and
that is that this
was during the real growth
of the industrial revolution,
and civilization as it expanded
involved a lot of pollution,
a lot of noise, and certainly
from Morris' viewpoint
it was just plain
ugly and disgusting.
And also in terms of romance
and romanticism looking back
this is not too long after
large numbers, maybe a majority
of the English farmers
were forcefully expelled
from their lands
to force them to be
wage slaves in the factories.
And so again he was looking
back to that and those aspects.
ROSALIND: You know more British
history than the average bear.
This is all very pertinent
to Morris particularly.
Similar things were
going on in France,
but Morris does something like
he takes a paddle on the rive,
and he's fishing, and he
notices that some agency, it's
like the equivalent of the
MDC, has trimmed the bushes
to make them less obtrusive.
But it's so ugly he says.
He writes letters
to the newspaper.
Just how can it be
so ugly, and then
the ducks can't swim among the
branches that you've trimmed.
It's not even just pollution.
It's the management.
Because he looks at the bush.
He doesn't see a bush.
He sees an agency, I mean
in the literal sense.
So that's really-- It doesn't
have to be destruction.
It can just be the
sense-- Well, again,
one of my favorite quotes
is from "Buckaroo Banzai."
Right? "No matter where
you go, there you are."
And that's one way of describing
what makes him so angry.
It's I can never get
away from people.
I'm always seeing evidence.
You know.
Any other questions?
Well, you know systems
can be very good at times
and they bring you lunch.
So I think maybe we'll
enjoy that together.
Thank you again for taking
the time and attention.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thanks.